Speaker 1: Well, it happened yesterday just
after we were done filming our Thursday show,
Judge Tunji Brown Jackson has been confirmed by
the Senate 53 to 47. She will be the first black
woman on the Supreme Court. It is a major deal and
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on it today
because we've basically spent the time already.
We've talked about her background. We've talked
about her qualifications. We've talked about some
of the most disgusting confirmation hearings that
we've seen. We've talked about Republicans saying
they're not going to vote for her without really
being able to explain why they're not going
to vote for her. We've talked about all of
it and now she's been confirmed, and indeed it
was a 53 to 47 vote. It was the 48 Democrats,
the two independents that caucus with
Democrats and the three Republicans that
we knew were going to support her because they
said so. And that was Senator Mitt Romney of Utah,
Senator Lisa Murkowski of Alaska and Senator Susan
Collins of Maine. No other Republican supporting
one of, if not the most qualified Supreme
Court nominees in. As long as I've been
covering Supreme Court confirmation hearings
and when compared to the nine justices
on the court up until now, as qualified as any of
them. So congratulations to her. We knew she'd be
confirmed and now the next battle is going to
be. What happens if Joe Biden gets another pick
after the midterms and Republicans have taken
control of the Senate? Mitch McConnell was
asked sometime in the last 24 hours if you guys
take the Senate in November. And Joe Biden gets
another pick. Would you even hold confirmation
hearings and Mitch McConnell declined to answer.
And it's the same Partizan nonsense we've
been talking about for a long time. So
that's it for now. The right decision made Judge
Jackson will soon be Justice Jackson on the court.